amman is with us in houston hey aman how
are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i wanted to ask you about uh the
situation i'm in so i'm deciding between
a 15 year fixed rate mortgage
or to save up and buy a home in cash so
the thing is i uh in my religion we have
a
20 um required charity so basically
at the end of the year any money we
didn't spend from our income
20 percent of is left over we have to
donate to charity
so if i were to save for a house i'd
have to pay a lot more in charity
which means it would you know take away
from my house savings but if i got a
mortgage
that money would be an expense so i'd
have to pay less charity and put more
towards the house
so with that 20 number what would you
recommend was
get a mortgage or save up for a house
and pay in cash
how old are you i'm 22. and what's your
income 160 000
wow how what in the world do you do at
22 years old making 160 000. what's
going to say
i'm a software engineer no of course you
are yeah
okay you're smart good for you way to go
okay so
what uh what are you gonna pay for this
house in cash or what are you gonna pay
for this house and how long is it gonna
take us to get there
uh i'm thinking around 300 000
and uh probably trying to save up over
the next four to five years
to pay for it cash yes how much do you
have cash right now in your savings
account
uh i have not started work yet but right
now i have about ten thousand dollars
oh so you're not working you're just
coming out of school yeah
okay so what would happen if you lived
like a college student
and did this in like three years
yeah i could do that and my expenses
would be pretty low yeah
and so the does the 20 apply
i i don't know the technicalities on on
your process
does that apply to whatever you have in
savings every year or what you added to
savings
this year what i added to savings this
year
okay and so if you put in a hundred
thousand it'd be 80 the next year if you
put in a hundred thousand b-80 and the
next year if you put in 100 000 it'd be
80 and you'd have 240 000
exactly okay and buy a 240 000 house at
25 years old cash
yeah yeah but would would it make more
sense to get a mortgage which would be
cheap like what sixty thousand percent
charity versus sixty thousand in
interest or less than sixty thousand
interest which could be
so what is your religion uh
i'm a a sect of islam called the shia
muslim
okay and um
i've got some friends that are muslims
that are doing some teaching on
what the koran says about uh money
and uh they're kind of building out you
know we're christians we kind of do it
from a christian perspective they're
doing it from a muslim perspective which
is very cool by the way
and uh they were teaching me that uh the
quran is
harder on debt than the bible is
yeah it is pretty tough on debt a lot of
people don't take any interest at all
actually
yeah not only the users issue but the
whole uh
the whole debt thing in general so i
don't know
i mean i i what i'm suggesting is maybe
you're choosing which part of the quran
you're going to be worried about here
and if you're worried about the debt
part you would get gladly give up the
other 20 percent
i kind of like i kind of like the saving
um you know
it mathematically doesn't work but yeah
technically charity doesn't work
mathematically
in general because when you give money
away you don't have it anymore
right uh and but yeah every religion of
quality suggests generosity of some in
some methodology christians
you know orthodox jews 10 tithe
you've got a 20 on savings there that
you're teaching me about that i wasn't
aware of
and uh so there it's not unusual at all
for
some methodology for generosity to be
built in
meaning that in general most religions
believe that god says we're better off
if we're generous
right right and so i don't think there's
a downside to you being generous
me neither instead of looking at it as a
duty look at it as a
an instruction from your religion that
is to your benefit
not even just a duty it's a yeah i
better say a benefit i like that dave
when you benefit from being a generous
person that is why you are getting this
instruction
to be generous and that's true i mean we
could say that
you know as christians we certainly
believe that that god is not telling us
to give money away
uh because he needs our money he said
money away because it changes your heart
into a generous person and generous
people are highly attractive but if
you're doing it as an active duty
then it's you're not getting that
benefit instead if you're doing it as an
act of
instruction where i'm seeing the benefit
of my character being changed to that of
a generous person which i suppose is
what the
the you know is this version of islam
that's what the goal is it would make
sense to me that that's how that works
but dave let's take away
religion from this if i'm 22 years old
and i'm making a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars a year
i'm staying at home and just going to
just save up and just buy a house cash
by 25.
and even if you take away the revenue
you have to stay home yeah i mean
you live on 60 grand exactly that's no
slouch no stops
at all a lot of people coming out of
college wish they made 60 grand
absolutely
so um you know that that's an okay
that's an okay version
i i still think i i mean it's an
interesting discussion and i like look i
like talking about it through this lens
because i think it's instructive but
um you know so so the point is that even
though your law even though you're
down by 20 i think your character is up
by more than 20
your generosity makes you more
attractive you are a better person
you on the long haul are going to
prosper i don't know that you're going
to prosper in this calendar year
by the equivalent of your giving that
probably seldom does happen
but i will tell you that generous people
over the scope of their life
tend towards prosperity because they're
more attractive
people want to do things with them
they're the ones that smile they're the
ones that hold the door for you they're
the ones you want to promote
now this is not someone who's acting out
of religious duty though
that's not generous that's just
following the rules being a
a religious boy scout yeah and that's
that doesn't give you that benefit
but uh the idea that generosity should
be
key in your financial plan if you are
doing it out of a compassionate loving
giving heart not a dutiful heart
i think it's a very important part of
the discussion i agree
i do so even all that aside if i can
save up and pay cash for three years
regardless of what rules i'm doing it
under
i'm doing that yes
yeah you're gonna be 25 years old not a
quarter or a hou own a home that's a
quarter of a million dollars
and you'll be making 200 000 a year
you're gonna be in good shape sir oh
yeah you're gonna be all right
oh yeah